a teenage survivor of the duck boat
accident near Branson Missouri is
talking about her ordeal first on CBS
this morning
14 year old Lauren Smith swam out of the
sinking boat to safety her father Steve
a 53 year old church deacon and her 15
year old brother Lance were among the 17
people who drowned CBS this morning
Saturday co-hosting at Jacobson spoke
with Lauren and her mother Dana good
morning good morning just unfathomable
tragedy here for this family Pam Smith
and her daughter Lauren agreed to an
interview with us in part because they
wanted to talk about their loved ones
Pam was the only member of the family
who wasn't on the boat Thursday she said
she needed to do some shopping so the
kids and their father set out to have
some fun her final conversation with her
husband took place just before the boat
sank he says it's not good words moments
after the end of that phone call between
her parents Lauren Smith says the duck
boat began filling with water
you know just murky water and I
swallowed a lot of it trying to breathe
how did you make it out I heard that you
helped someone else though too I saw
someone struggling I went up to push up
their feet Lauren says the waves
eventually pushed her toward the dock
and she clung on until someone pulled
her out her father Steve and brother
Lance didn't make it Pam Smith later
found her 14 year old daughter at the
hospital I think I kissed her a thousand
times because I love her so did the
heart sight too because Lance wasn't
there how did the two of you as a family
deal with this long prayers we're gonna
have to lean on people she's all I've
got now
we're gonna take care of each other the
Smith family makes the roughly 200 mile
trip from their home in Osceola Arkansas
to Branson Missouri nearly every summer
Pam and Steve had been married almost 28
years he liked to talk to anybody you
never met a stranger was just an
exceptional guy how do you want the two
of them to be remembered for their
Christian walk
Lance he was recently this past Sunday
he preached and I was so proud it is
mini sermon was um being a good example
it's a two p court everybody just loved
it it's like losing one of your best
friends I'm gonna close this best
friends you'll never separate from have
you thought a lot about that time on the
boat thinking why me why do I have to
leave you got to live to share your
brother's memory and your father and you
have purpose you have a purpose Lauren
you got big things ahead of you think I
know I needed you now a lot of people
have been wondering why the duck boat
was allowed to go out on the water under
those conditions Thursday Lauren says
the sky was clear and the water was calm
when they first set out and then halfway
through the trip conditions took a
sudden turn for the worse with tragic
results obviously we've heard that from
people who have talked about the
incident that same exact thing but that
story was so hard Dana that she would
get a call from her husband and say Pam
this isn't good yeah that's what that's
what haunts me that they knew how bad
this yeah she saw the weather warning
when she was shopping so she called them
and then when she hung up with him she
tried to reach him again couldn't reach
him and then was waiting to hear it it's
unfathomable she did not have on a life
- no she told us that they were never
told to put on the lifejackets they got
a very quick safety briefing in the
beginning and she really didn't know she
talked about trying to struggle to get
out but it wasn't clear exactly how she
was able to and then she just came up it
was such a mom moved to the way she
tenderly
moved her daughter's hair and she said
God no God knows that I needed her it's
just guy stuff they have their church at
home that's really embraced them as well
which I know she told me has helped them
tremendously talks about needing to lean
on people thank God she has that church
and that they have each other maybe she
ate them sharing the story though very
much so very much so honoring as far as
it is to here
thank you very much Dana